hey everybody it's Adam Savage from test
comm and Discovery Channel's MythBusters
I am at comic-con 2013 this is where
hundred and forty thousand people are
going to gather this week to celebrate
culture science fiction fantasy and
costuming and this year Wired magazine
in conjunction with Conde Nast
Entertainment YouTube and the building
mad geniuses Stan Winston school and
legacy effects have decided to jump into
the costuming fray and they've jumped
hard behind me is something that they're
calling this the robot I have not seen
it yet I swear I'm gonna see it for the
first time in just a second you're gonna
see it with me let's see
these guys built this in 24 days
[Music]
anyway this guy's gonna be wandering all
over Comic Con this week look out for
him and look out for a chance to name
him
I'm Adam Savage let's get costuming
[Music]